I'm shoppers can now return to most of
their favorite stores but when you walk
in you might notice the racks are pretty
bare
Kristen Drummond is live in the South
West Valley with the reason tonight
Kristen Denise availability seems slim
right now at stores like Ross I went
inside this one near the 215 and South
Rainbow today there were hardly clothes
on the racks like we're normally
expecting at a store like Ross and the
retail Association of Nevada tells me
it's because of a disruption in the
supply chain it's an issue impacting
retailers across the state the
Association says various factors are
contributing to the lack of inventory
and that includes the pandemic and
Chinese manufacturing slowing down
because of the decline in consumer
demand those issues go beyond clothing
to tech and businesses selling goods the
Association anticipates more delays in
products as the Year continues it's
early still so but we can expect I think
some sort of supply chain disruption as
it comes into the third and fourth
quarter holiday for retail
shortages also continue at grocery
stores meat remains an issue because of
certain processing plants closing
temporarily and there's also limited
baking items and ingredients like yeast
due to a surgeon baking interest
according to the national grocers
Association but paper goods and cleaning
product demands have returned to normal
now not seeing a huge decline are
actually comfort clothing like pajama
slippers sweatpants and retail experts
say because there is still a demand for
that type of clothing it does seem that
people are still continuing to hunker
down during the pandemic reporting live
in the Southwest Valley Kristin Drummond
8 news now alright so we asked some of
our shoppers out there have you been
able to find everything you need in the
stores and it's been fairly split 51%
saying yep finding what I need and 49%
saying no